now my next guest served his country as
vice president without enriching his
family through foreign cash and recently
he did drop out of the 2024 race for
president but he's continued to advocate
for American values by the way he and
his daughter authored a brand new book
and it is entitled go home for dinner
advice from how Faith makes a family and
family makes a life joining us now
former vice president Mike Pence and his
daughter Charlotte Pence uh bonder with
us Mr Vice president before we get to
this this really novel idea cuz I have
not been home for dinner uh I'm now in
my 28th year at Fox so I'm kind of
guilty of being absent from a lot of
dinners but um let me ask you about what
we see unfolding in Israel what we see
unfolding in the world some of the
questioning the line of questioning I
was I was bringing up with Ambassador
Haley um Nick I'm just curious none of
these institutions seem to be working
and you handled things very differently
in the Trump Administration for example
you were a lot tougher on China for
example you put tariffs on China and my
understanding is and you can correct me
if I'm wrong my sources tell me that
when it came to conversations that you
and president Trump had with President
Chi they were brutally honest and what
the response would be if he acted the
wrong way is that
true uh that that's absolutely true and
you know it was 5 years ago that I I
represented uh the administration at the
APAC conference I met president X and uh
uh different than uh you know dinner and
Cocktails and warm conversations and and
agreements uh like we heard announced
tonight although I I welcome the fentol
cooperation uh at at that APAC
conference in Papa New Guinea I gave a
very tough speech I told China that we
were done with their military
provocations in the Asia Pacific we were
done with their trade abuses uh we had
invested a record amount in in our
military uh and in a short period of
time we impose $250 billion in tariffs
on China uh you know I I don't know
exactly what happened in San Francisco
it doesn't sound like much came from it
at all but the thing I know having uh
having uh spoken to president G having
been at uh a forum identical to that
with him China understands strength uh
and this is a moment of time where we
have an Administration that from the
disastrous withdrawal uh from
Afghanistan uh from uh the the weakness
that Joe Biden has projected around the
world uh the cow Towing to China uh
begging Iran to get back in the in the
Iran nuclear deal I mean now more than
ever uh we need new leadership in this
country and we need a projection of
strength uh and I I say just as a
private citizen no longer involved in
active politics Sean that I didn't sense
strength in our president's words
tonight uh I didn't feel that he was
forceful at all and I think there's a
lot more that he could have done do you
believe I'm I'm correct in my belief
that China Russia Iran North Korea have
formed a new axis of
Evil I I don't think there's any
question about that it's one of the
reasons why I you know if as as I've
said many times we need to speak with
one voice in this country that America
stands with Israel as Israel does the
hard work which is going to be not days
but months to hunt down and Destroy
Hamas but I also believe that America
needs to continue to stand with the
people of Ukraine until they repel that
Russian invasion because Russia and Iran
and China and North Korea have created a
new axis uh and standing in solidarity
as the leader of the Free World is is
the only role for the United States of
America
Hey listen uh let me switch gears if I
may and and uh Charlotte uh Pence Bon
great to have you and you wrote this
book with your dad go home for dinner
advice on how Faith makes a family and a
family makes a life and I was watching
your interview on Fox and Friends and
you guys were great together um I can't
imagine your dad angry and pissed off I
can't imagine him yelling did he ever
have a few of those moments cuz he's a
very even-tempered man
he is extremely even tempered I had uh
one of the makeup artists at Fox asked
me she said he's so nice is he always
that nice and I said Yes actually he is
always that nice um I mean of of you
know of course we have our disagreements
as a family and I think everybody does
and that's one of the things we actually
talk about in this book is that the
dinner table is where family members
learn how to disagree with one another
and it's something that I think
Americans could could learn how to do a
little bit
better I was shocked when your dad
described his when he was growing up he
wasn't allowed to speak at the dinner
table that it was it was dad's time to
speak mom's time to speak but the kids
were not allowed to speak uh did that
happen at your dinner
table no it didn't actually um I think
you know we we have a chapter in the
book that's about parents listening it
says be a parent who listens and I think
my parents did that really well um and
taught us how to respect one another and
let everybody take a turn talking um but
uh you know I don't I don't think it's
done him any harm I think he's he's done
while speaking in his life
sense anyway the book is phenomenal yeah
yeah Sean I really do believe there's a
my daughter and I my daughter and I
wrote this book together and um uh and
it's a it's a it's meant to be a very
personal story about our family but
we're a very typical average American
family but by putting faith and time
with our family first uh We've really
been blessed and uh we hope people will
grab a copy of go home for dinner
because I think I think uh you know as I
said in the beginning here talking about
large Global issues we we need a
stronger America but the strength of
this country has always come from our
faith and our families and the best way
to strengthen families today and
strength in America is to go home for
dinner all right thank you Mr Vice
President charlot great to see you too
good luck with the book amazon.com
bookstores around the country hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else